OSSAMA ALAMI: Hello, everybody,
and welcome to
Bring Your App to
the Big Screen.
This session is all about
designing TV applications,
designing for Google TV.
Before we get started, my
name's Ossama Alami.
I manage the Developer Relations
team for Google TV,
and I'm co-presenting here
today with Michael
Sundermeyer, who leads
our UX team.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
OSSAMA ALAMI: Big
fans of Michael.
So by show of hands, can I see
how many of you are Android
developers or have built
an Android app?
Great.
I think that's about half.
And how many of you have built
an app for Google TV, either
Android or a web app?
A smattering.
So this session is going to be
a great for those of you that
have built apps and great for
those of you that haven't.
The biggest thing to building
a TV application is probably
design, because it's very
different from mobile or
tablets or even PC
or web design.
Designing for TV is designing
for a different user
experience.
So as a refresher, I'll go over
what Google TV is for
those of you that don't know.
Google TV is Android
optimized for TV.
It comes with Google Chrome,
and it comes with Google
services like search, a
discovery experience called TV
and Movies, photos, YouTube,
and other applications.
And it comes with live
TV integration.
So Google TV is really about
integrating the live TV with
the web, bringing the best of TV
and the best of the web and
trying to make it the best
experience possible, bring as
much content as possible to the
user where they're looking
to be entertained when they're
on the couch in
front of their TV.
So last October, we launched a
major update to Google TV.
We vastly simplified the UI,
the user experience.
We improved search
and discovery.
We released a new YouTube
experience for Google TV.
And critically, for most of you
guys, we launched Android
Market, now Google Play, and the
ability for you to build
applications and reach users
on their TVs and distribute
those applications through
Google Play.
So a lot of what we learned in
simplifying the UI and making
a better user experience in our
second-generation software
we're going to teach
you about today.
They're very exciting in
the session next door.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
OSSAMA ALAMI: There we go.
Yeah!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE CONTINUE]
OSSAMA ALAMI: Thank
you for that.
I'm sure you're all very excited
about our new devices.
We have new devices that
launched this week and over
the last couple weeks.
They're out in the sandbox.
On this level, I encourage you
guys to check them out.
I'm very excited about
these things.
They all have the
ARM processor.
They're shipping in the US, and
the Sony devices are going
to be available internationally.
So Sony has released a buddy
box, and they have a Blu-ray
player that they're demoing.
Vizio released a buddy box
earlier this week.
And LG has a series of TVs
with Google TV built in.
And I'm happy to announce that
later this summer we'll be
releasing an updated Google
Play store for Google TV.
This will add some the features
you heard about
yesterday, subscription billing
support, partial
updates, as well as the ability
for users to purchase
music, videos, and now TV shows
directly from their TV.
This is the first year we're
doing a full track for Google
TV at IO, and I'm really excited
about this session and
the other sessions.
I'm going to quickly tell
you about the other
two sessions we have.
If you're interested about DRM,
streaming video, and the
enhancements that we made to
Google TV there, if you're
interested about getting your
content on TV, I encourage you
to check out this session
after lunch.
And today a lot of TV users
are distracted users.
They're sitting on their couch
with a mobile phone or a
tablet or a PC, a laptop.
And part of the time they're
watching TV, they're also on
those devices.
So if you want to learn how to
build a unique experience that
connects the user on their
second screen device, on their
mobile phone or tablet, as well
as on the TV that they're
watching, build a cohesive
experience around your
application, go to this session,
and we'll teach you a
little about the technologies we
have to make that possible.
So why do you care?
Why do you care about
building for TV?
TVs have been around for a long
time, and it turns out
there are a whole lot of them.
In the US, there are more
TVs than people.
On average, 2 and 1/2 people
in a home and 2.93 TV sets.
This stat is actually going up,
even though the rise of
smartphones and tablets.
People continue to watch TV.
People continue to buy TVs.
This is really about meeting
the user in the
living room, right?
Meeting the user where they're
looking to be entertained.
And they still want to be
entertained on their
televisions.
And they watch a whole
lot of television.
In the US, on average, five
hours of TV per day.
So this is an opportunity for
you guys as developers to
finally meet the users with the
five hours of TV watching
they're doing per day as well
as the other amount of time
that the TV sits off.
Think about an experience
that is uniquely
appropriate for the TV.
And it continues to grow.
So this stat's by
DisplaySearch.
By 2015, over 500 million
connected
TVs will have shipped.
Connected TVs or smart TVs.
And that year, 47% of flat
panels shipped that year will
be smart TVs.
So Google TV really aims to be
an open app platform for you
guys as developers to build
applications and for
manufacturers to build
a smart TV.
Users are become accustomed
having access on the content
that they love on all
of their devices.
That includes the TV now.
If you have an application that
is meant to entertain or
maybe inform the user, it's
a great TV application.
And users, as they get more
and more familiar with
connected TVs and smart TVs,
are really going to
want that app there.
So reach and delight your users
where they're looking to
be entertained.
And how you do this?
Well, there are two ways right
now to build for Google TV.
It is an Android device, so you
can build an Android app.
And it does ship with a full
desktop version of Google
Chrome, so you can
build a web app.
When I say build an Android app,
it's really just that.
The Google TV SDK is
the Android SDK.
What we're going to teach you
about in this session is how
to design that app for TV.
But if you already have
experience building Android
applications, that's great.
You already know most of
what you need to know
to build a TV app.
And you get the advantage of
distributing and monetizing
that app and discoverability
options through Google
Play on Google TV.
Or build a web app.
Your site's already accessible
on Chrome in Google TV, but
what we're going to teach you
here today is how to optimize
that experience for TV viewers,
how to make it really
great on the web browser
that we ship with.
Those are the two options for
building for Google TV.
We're not going to go into the
depths of how to build an
Android app or how to
build a web app.
There's lots of sessions here
at I/O that'll teach you how
to do that.
What we're really going to do
is we're going to teach you
how to design a great TV app.
And since I'm not the
expert on that, I'm
going to call up Michael.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
Thank you.
Thank you, Ossama.
Hello, everybody.
I'm Michael.
I head up the design
of Google TV.
And I haven't been with the team
very long, but I've been
designing for TV and mobile
devices for many years.
So I know enough to be a
little bit dangerous.
So this session is all about the
experience you can create
with the technology, not about
the technology itself.
So unlike most sessions, I'm
not going to show a single
line of code.
So please don't go run screaming
from the room yet.
Hopefully we'll show a few
things that are interesting,
and you'll learn
something new.
TV is really evolving.
Google TV is not your
grandfather's TV.
TV has not fundamentally changed
in the last 30 years
since cable television came
around until just recently.
And now a few things have
started to move around that
are really changing the
landscape of TV.
First, the TV screens
that we have in our
homes are getting big.
They're getting really
big, huge.
They're flat.
They're thin.
They're beautiful.
And they can go anywhere
in your home.
They're appearing in places that
we wouldn't have expected
before like kitchens and family
rooms and bathrooms.
They're appearing in
our workplaces.
So they're appearing
everywhere.
They're more like big screens
that are just omnipresent
present in our lives.
Second, they are smart.
Right now, more than 30% of all
the TVs that ship in the
United States are smart TVs.
And that number is growing,
as Ossama said.
Pretty soon, pretty much all
of them will be smart TVs.
They'll have a CPU and GPU in
the device itself, which
enables web and applications
and a huge amount of new
content and new capabilities
that we can take advantage of.
And then third, they're
interactive.
There are new ways
of interacting.
The controllers that we
have have cursors on
them and track pads.
We're starting to see voice.
We're seeing gesture.
We're interacting with them,
just starting to be able to
interact with them with our
mobile phones and with our
tablets and our computers.
So there's a whole bunch of
new opportunities around
interaction.
So I'm here to talk to you
about how some of these
disruptive changes to the
landscape of, really, the
living room present new
opportunities for creating
great experiences for
the home that
really connect us together.
But here's the thing.
So I think we're only just
beginning to figure out how to
create great experiences
on any device.
We're right at the beginning.
We're in our infancy.
I've been doing this for 15
years, and I still learn
something new every
single day.
So I don't have all the answers
here, but I'm going to
present some of the things that
we've learned so far and
leave it in your good hands
to take it from there.
I'll start by talking about the
big screen, what it's good
for what and what it's
not so good for.
You may not be aware of some
of the differences there.
Then I'll show you a few
applications and how their
developers used different
strategies to bring Android
applications, web applications
from mobile devices and the
web to the television.
Then I'll spend a little time
talking about designing,
giving you some design tips for
designing for TV around
interaction and design
and layout.
And then finally, I'm going to
share with you a few inside
trade secrets for how to
actually make a great
application, not just usable.
But I hope to inspire you to go
beyond thinking about just
the basics to creating an
application that's beautiful
and compelling and cinematic
and that people
really love to use.
All right.
So let's start with
the big screen.
So what's different about
the big screen?
Well, it's really big.
And it's great for video
and images and simple
interactivity, anything that's
really visual and cinematic.
The 10-foot experience has been
designed for consumption,
so people are used to leaning
back a little more.
And I'll talk about that.
And they're connected to
big sound systems.
So it's great for
music and video.
But what you may not know is
there's a few things--
a lot of people think, well,
I just take my tablet
application, and I'll
bring it to the TV,
and will work great.
The TV is not a big
tablet, actually.
There's a few things that
tablets are great for that TV
is not so good for.
For example, reading a lot of
text is not great on a TV.
Because you're 10 feet away, the
information density needs
to be less than you might
think on a tablet.
And because it's really a
lean-back experience-- there's
something that happens when we
sit down in the cushions, we
sink back, we grab a beer and
our controller, we dim the
lights, and we go to
watch something.
We relax, and we're really
in a different mode.
And that may change
over time as these
devices become more capable.
But for now people really get
into a certain mode, and
they're not used to doing
certain kind of activities on
a TV that they might do on
a tablet or computer.
So really, we've found that it's
actually better to think
of a TV more like a phone in
terms of design than a tablet.
If you hold a phone about this
far away, that's about the
size in your field of vision
that a TV is 10 feet away.
The amount of screen density,
the amount of text, the amount
of interactivity is about the
same on a little device like
this than it is on a big TV.
So it's a little surprising
that it's
different than a tablet.
TVs are also really social.
Just all the same qualities that
make a TV fantastic for
watching movies, playing games
together make it great for
shared experiences, but one
thing that's different is that
people are used to using a TV
for entertainment and not so
much for work.
So it's great for games, for
education, for apps around
exploration like maps and travel
and food and things
that connect to us personally.
But people aren't so used to
doing their email on a big TV.
Some of you may do it.
Many of you may do it.
But we're unusual.
We're a little different than
the average consumer, who
still uses the living room
as kind of a different
space than an office.
You also have to think about
privacy, especially around
social networks and financial
websites and things like that.
And you really need to think
about the multi-user and how
different users may use the
space and the applications
differently in the shared
space, how they use it
separately and together.
So not all applications that
are successful on a phone,
like I said, move over to
the TV successfully.
But it's pretty straightforward
to move an
Android application.
If you've got an Android
application, as Ossama said,
you're already soaking
in the technology.
And then it's really just about
understanding what are
the main differences between the
two in terms of the design
and the erection.
Applications take different
paths to get to the TV.
And I want to show you three
different paths in the form of
application developers that
have done it already.
Pandora is a simple and
elegant music app.
You probably mostly use it.
I love it.
It's really designed
on the phone.
It's already designed
really well.
It's big.
It's visual.
It's sort of lean back.
It taps into the sound system.
So moving that to TV was
really pretty easy.
This is the phone app on the
upper right and the TV app on
the lower left.
They really didn't have to
change a lot for this
application.
One of the main things they
did is just enable the
transport controls, the
Play-Pause controls on the
remote control.
So there's a couple extra things
they had to do there.
So this one is where they really
used a similar design
for both mobile and TV.
CNBC took a different route.
They tapped into the strengths
of each device and did
something slightly different.
So on the phone, it's really
good for interacting with your
stock portfolio.
On the tablet, it's great for
reading in-depth articles.
So there's a lot of
text in articles.
And then on the TV, which is
great for video, they brought
their video window to
the foreground and
made it really big.
So there are common elements
among all three of the
platforms for this application,
but they've
highlighted different ones
in different platforms.
So they've really taken
advantage of the
strengths of each.
Flixster radically simplified
their tablet
application for the TV.
So where their tablet
application has a lot of text,
they removed almost
all the text.
They made big images, big fonts,
dark backgrounds and
gradients, made it more simple
both in terms of navigation
and in terms of visually.
So in this case, they just took
their tablet application,
and they really simplified it
and pulled some things out
until it was right for the TV.
So those are three really
common strategies
for moving to TV--
mapping it over pretty directly
if your app is right,
using the strengths of each
application, of each device
and they're just simplifying
what you've
got on another platform.
So now I'm going to dive into
some of the basic design
considerations for television
in three areas.
The first is interaction.
So the almighty D-Pad has been
around for 30 years, and it
just won't die.
It's still around.
And even in Google TV, you
need to develop your
applications so that they're
navigable by D-Pad.
In this case, we've got
two different kinds.
I'm sorry.
These are all three.
So Vizio, Sony, and
LG all have D-Pad.
They're slightly different.
For example, the LG has a scroll
wheel, which is really
nice for scrolling.
But the D-Pad is--
it's surprising, actually.
There's a reason why it's
stood the test of time.
It's really a lean-back
device.
If you think about it, you
don't have to look down.
You can just put your
arm at your side.
You can really focus on
what's on your screen.
You can use it in the dark.
It doesn't feel like work.
You don't have to think
about it at all.
So there's a reason why it's
actually successful even
though it's so simple, and
that's part of the reason it
is successful is it
is so simple.
But it's surprisingly
different.
So we're designing applications
for both TV and
for tablet and phones.
It's surprisingly difficult to
make them the same sometimes
depending on the app.
The interaction models are just
oh so subtly different
that you kind of have to decide
in your application to
go one way or the other, really
make it the same and
kind of designed to the lowest
common denominator of the
interaction model or really make
them different and take
advantage of the strengths of
touch versus D-Pad and cursor.
These devices all have
cursors as well.
All Google TV remote controls
are required to have a cursor
of some sort.
But they have different kinds.
So the Vizio and the Sony on the
left have track pads, and
they have an integrated
select button.
You just push on the track
pad wherever you are.
And then the LG has an
integrated wand very much like
a Wii remote but a little
higher fidelity.
And so this means that
you do have the
ability to use cursor.
And it's tempting to use
that to emulate touch.
But cursor doesn't quite
equal touch.
There's a way in which these
devices have such a physical
connection when you touch it.
You reach out, and you're
touching and dragging and
swiping the thing that you
reached out to touch that
have-- it taps into hundreds
of thousands of years of
evolution of humans making
that connection.
Where with a cursor, you're 10
feet away, and it's a little
bit more work to try and
grab the thing you
want and move it.
So it's just slightly
different,
we found, from touch.
And the other thing is that the
way we do cursor on these
different controllers is
slightly different.
So track pad has some different
strengths than a wand has.
So what I mean is it's not
as consistent as touch.
So for those two reasons, we
recommend that people really
design their apps around D-Pad
navigation first and then use
the cursor as an accelerator
to that navigation.
It's best for low-twitch
interactions like Angry Birds.
And you really-- you
kind of want to--
the developers made
me say this.
You got to stay away from
drag and drop as well.
Sometimes the D-Pads--
I'm sorry-- the track
pads are hard.
When you click and drag, it
takes a fair amount of force
on your thumb.
If you use that as a main
interaction model, sometimes
some people have trouble
with it.
And then finally, you need
big hit targets.
The screens are so big.
You think about it, just a
little translation of angle
here moves it a lot
on the big screen.
And so you really need bigger
hit targets than you might
have even in touch.
D-Pad is really a linear
interaction model.
You think about it
almost like the
old-fashioned cassette tapes--
I'm dating myself-- where you
had to fast-forward through
four songs to get to
the fifth song.
And then touch is more like
RAM, random access memory,
where you can just touch
whatever you want.
So because it's linear, you have
to think more about the
navigation that you're
presenting to your users.
The focus states in the layout
help the user predict how to
get from point A to point B. But
they have to think about
it a bit, and you need to
think about it as well.
It needs to be continuous.
You don't want the focus to have
to jump across the screen
and between big states.
In an Android, the focus order
tends to follow the way that
the components are laid out
on the screen by a layout
manager, for example.
And so we find that it's better
if you explicitly
manage the focus in your
application rather than
letting the system do it.
So there's three types of focus,
three states actually.
So there's selection.
There's focus, and there's
focused selection.
So the first is really
familiar.
Selection is--
this is a tab, for example.
This is the Shows tab
of a TV movies app.
The tab or a section of an
application is a more
permanent state-- not permanent,
but it lives for a
longer time.
The focus state is--
it shows the position of the
D-Pad as the user moves the
focus around.
It needs to be big and
really visible.
Like this blue glowing
rectangle, I actually think
that's not even strong enough.
Maybe it could be stronger,
because the user needs to be
able to just look up at the
screen and know exactly where
the D-Pad is.
Because everything
goes from there.
And then the third thing is,
like a cursor, you can hover
over a particular area.
And with D-Pad, wherever the
focus is, we do things like
after a second, if the user
keeps the focus on that area,
we can pop up a hover card
like this and give more
information and progressively
reveal more info.
So some views in Android, like
the image views, they're not
focusable by default.
So the one code thing I'll say
is you have to turn on the
focusable attribute
to turn this on.
And we also think you should
explicitly manage
the order of focus.
All right.
Keyboards.
All remotes for Google
TV have to have
a hard QWERTY keyboard.
They started out being big, and
now they're on the back of
the generation of remotes
that happen now.
The one thing to think about
is in the next generation
coming out next year,
we're making the
hard keyboard optional.
And so you'll have to make sure
that your applications
support on-screen keyboards.
It'll just be the standard
Android keyboard.
Each manufacturer will create
their own variation of it, but
it should work just fine
other than it will
support D-Pad and cursor.
OK.
And the last interaction
model, of course, is
multiscreen experiences.
We've seen a lot of great
experiences, like this
mobile poker app.
Zynga Poker is upstairs as well,
where the table is on
the big screen, and each person
literally has their own
hand of cards in their own hand
on their mobile device.
But we've only just begun.
I mean, this is brand-new
area of opportunity.
So we're really looking
forward to
what you guys create.
All right.
A couple areas of design.
A couple design tips.
So this is the Google music
beta app from a
while ago on the web.
So what would be wrong with just
putting this on the TV?
Anybody spot any problems
with this app?
A lot of text.
Not available in Australia.
Make everything available
in Australia.
Very important design
consideration.
Yes, there's way
too much text.
The information density
is very high.
The fonts are really small.
But really one of the big ones
is-- and it's hard to think
about is it's all white.
In the environments where we
watch TV, on these big
screens, as they get
bigger it's like
looking at a light bulb.
You have so much light emanating
at you in a dark
rook that it can be
really blinding.
So this is one of the biggest
changes from the web, where
most backgrounds are white to
TV, where most backgrounds
really need to be dark.
Also you have to be careful
about using
certain reds and oranges.
They vibrate and don't translate
very well to TV.
This orange might OK.
I don't know for sure.
And then finally, this app
is very text heavy.
You really want to think about
how your application can
communicate better visually.
Visual things are much
better on TV.
Here's an example of the same
app, a different part of it.
But it's a little easier on
the eyes on the TV and on
these big screens, where there's
a dark background.
There's a gradient that gives
it a little bit of depth,
makes it feel a little
more cinematic.
It's more visual, bigger
fonts, bigger icons.
And, really, there's a lot less
chrome and buttony kind
of things so that the content
can kind of breathe.
Layout is a tricky thing because
of the navigation.
The first thing about laying out
an application for TV is
something that's been around
for a long time.
So let's take a simple UI like
this and put it on an
old-fashioned tube TV.
And what you get is the
edges are all cut off.
So those of us who were
designing TV applications 15
years ago, we had to think about
this thing called, well,
safe area or over scan.
Because the tubes were not
rectangular, the light guns
couldn't reach the corners.
And so each TV manufacturer had
to reduce the amount of
space that was available.
So it was fine to just design
with the safe area, just
design to keep your
application in the
middle of the TV.
The problem was every
TV was different.
The amount of space that you had
to waste was really large,
because you had to design for
the worst TV in the world,
which I don't know what
it was at the time.
But it was must've been bad,
because you had to put a big
space around it.
So you'd think that this
situation is no more, but, in
fact, it lives on.
But it's a little bit better.
LED TVs still have this idea
of over scan, but the over
scan is less, because we don't
have tubes anymore.
And Google TV actually added
something where at install
time, we ask users to calibrate
their over scan.
So they expand the maximum
visible space of their TV.
So we can use as much space
as is possible on that TV.
It still means that there
is some amount of your
application that will not appear
on some TVs, but it
means that the top left will
always be visible.
It's guaranteed to be visible.
It's the bottom right corner
that may get cut off.
And what we say is try to design
around the idea-- well,
the moral really is, is use
flexible layouts and try to
design around keeping about 5%
of the bottom and right halves
of your screen not required
to be seen by users.
They may get cut off.
Next, there are two densities
that Android provides for
television.
One is XHDPI, which is 1080p.
And the other is TVDPI, which
most people don't know about.
It's fairly new.
It's 720p.
Now what's the differences?
You don't have to develop
for both.
If you develop for 720p,
it will scale up.
1080 will scale down if
the TV is a 720 TV.
So you only have to
develop for one.
The one thing you need
to know about is
there's a trade-off there.
1080p, of course, the image
quality is better.
The video quality is better.
720p, the performance of
animations is better.
Because you're pushing around
roughly a third of the pixels
with 720p, it uses less memory,
less processor power.
It takes less time to open
images and that sort of thing.
So you just really need to
think about the type of
application you have.
Google TV uses 1080p for all
of our applications.
But it may be that if you're
creating a game, you want to
create 720, because the
animation is so important.
So it's just trade-off
to know about.
In terms of layouts, you want
to keep really simple, basic
zones of layouts.
Because of the wide aspect ratio
of a television, it's
typically better to put the
navigation on the left and
right than the top
and the bottom.
If you put it on the top and
the bottom, you leave very
little space for your content.
So in Google TV, we use
this pattern a lot.
We use a global navigation
vertically along the left.
We put the content
in the middle.
And then we have an optional
area of contextual menu that
gives more options
if you need it.
But we typically don't
use that for much.
If you look at the YouTube app
on Google TV, you'll see that
it uses the contextual menu.
There's a number of
other patterns.
Here are some.
There's the shelf model that
scrolls left and right.
There's the grid model, which
scrolls up and down.
There's tabs.
There's lists.
There's lots of different
models.
As long as you're consistent,
you should be OK.
The one thing to avoid is
D-Pad interaction traps.
It's something that you don't
necessarily think about at the
beginning, but you can get the
user in a pickle where they
can't get out of it.
So in this case, I've got
navigation along the top,
navigation along the bottom.
If I move the D-Pad to the
middle, it's a scrolling list.
So if I hit down, down, down,
it's actually scrolling down
in the list.
If that list has 100 things in
it, you're never going to be
able to get down to the
navigation at the bottom.
It's going to be like that guy
that climbs one rise and sees
the next rise and climbs that
and sees the next one.
They're going to keep trying to
get there, and they won't
be able to.
So you have to be
aware of that.
OK, so, so much for the basics
of designing a usable
application.
Those are the main
considerations.
Not a lot, but a few things
to think about.
So how do you make something
that's great?
If only there were a recipe book
for great experiences.
But if there were a recipe book,
if I could just hand you
this, then why aren't
all apps great?
Why is it so hard to do?
Well, I kind of think about
it like making movies.
When you make a movie, there's
no book to teach you how to
make a great movie,
a hit movie.
There's lots of books on the
mechanics of it, the
techniques around lighting and
cinematography and acting, but
there's nothing that puts
it all together.
The greatness really comes in
tapping into the deeper user
motivations.
What really drives people,
what people love?
So I want to share a couple of
trade secrets in the form six
design principles that we use
constantly when we're
designing TV applications.
Some of them may be familiar to
you, but it's really in how
you apply them that counts.
The first is content is king.
And you've heard this before,
but it is the most important
design principle in making
a great application.
Content is king.
So much of application
development involves thinking
about layouts and UI and chrome,
buttons, and check
boxes that often we leave the
actual content until the end.
We neglect the content.
But if you think about it,
really, chrome is just--
not the browser Chrome.
The actual Chrome of the UI is a
barrier between the user and
what they really want, which
is their content.
So we say design the content,
not the UI.
Design the content,
So much so that I'll tell
you a quick story.
Once I was giving a design
talk in the Bay
Area a long time ago.
And I used Bank of America
online banking as an example
an experience that could be
better, to put it mildly.
And I went into the
reasons why.
And after the talk, a guy
came up to me and
handed me his card.
And it said VP of User
Experience, Bank of America.
And I was like, OK, sorry.
But he said, no, no, you're
totally right.
Let's work together
to make it better.
And so we started working
together, and he said, OK, why
don't you guys do a first pass
and send us some wire frames,
send us some ideas about
what you want?
I'm like, we don't
work that way.
We don't do wire frames.
We design the content.
We need user accounts.
He's like, user accounts?
I can't give you
user accounts.
That's, like, private
information.
I'm like, well, we design
the content.
And the user account information
is the content.
Finally, he relented, and
he gave us his accounts.
He gave us all his checking,
banking, credit
cards for two years.
He gave us all of
his accounts.
And we spent a week-- all of
us designers spent a week
poring over that data and really
looking at the ebb and
flow of this guy's accounts,
what he spent on and when his
PG&E bill was due and when
his rent was late
and all these things.
And from that, we looked at
patterns and what could we do
to really help a user manage
their finances.
And really, it's a really
clear example of really
starting from the content ,
thinking from the content, and
seeing it through
the user's eyes.
So here's another example
on Google TV.
This is an application
called Redux.
It is a beautiful, lovely,
simple video
app for Google TV.
It really celebrates the
content, which is, in this
case, video.
It pulls YouTube videos
and puts them
into curated channels.
The video is full screen.
The UI is not visible at all
until the user calls it up.
And when it does come up, it
lives very lightly on top.
They use a lot of transparency
and text
and very simple icons.
It's not big, garish, colorful
buttons that are dragging you
away from the content.
It really keeps you
in the experience.
And really the content's
in charge here.
The content's in charge, and
the UI lives to serve.
It's a great example of
contents is king.
The second principle
is less is more.
You've heard this before too.
Mark Twain once said, if I had
more time, I would have
written less.
Less is hard.
Simple is hard.
But simple isn't just
throwing things out.
Simple is about focus.
It is about knowing
what you're about.
It is about knowing what your
users need and when they need
it and only providing that
at the right time.
So we say focus on 80%.
And what we mean this, we mean
really focus on the 80% use
cases, the things that users do
all the time, most users.
Make those sing.
Make those great.
Don't compromise on those.
And make the 20% edge cases
possible, but don't make them
dilute the power of the
80% part of it.
Let's see.
We use visual hierarchy
as well to
emphasize what's important.
And we use progressive
disclosure to only reveal
things as they're needed.
And we let the content
breathe.
So an example is here on
the TV and Movies app.
In the first version,
we built it for
scanning a lot of content.
And so, as you can see,
we threw a lot of
stuff on the screen.
There's a lot of images.
There's three lines of text for
every single movie that
you're looking at or TV
show in this case.
And everything is equal.
The visual weight, everything's
bold.
The text is almost all
the same size.
And when you look at users
using an application like
this, you find that their
eyes jump around.
They don't really know
what to focus on.
It's hard for them to parse and
hard for them to navigate.
So we redesigned this recently
in a couple simple ways.
One is we got rid
of all the text.
You don't need the text until
you need the text.
And we made this central
shelf bigger.
The icons are much bigger.
And we used-- on this visual
hierarchy, meaning the central
focus, that central shelf
is brighter, and
the others are dimmer.
And then we added a hover card
so that if your attention is
focused on one thing for more
than a second, then more
information reveals itself.
So these are just a few simple
ways in which we made the
application feel cleaner and
calmer, and it delivers just
the right information
at the right time.
The third principle is
movement has meaning.
And a lot of developers seem
to think that animation is
gratuitous, and they leave it
to the end or leave it out.
But we actually use animation in
very subtle ways and not so
subtle ways to really
communicate where somebody is
and help guide and
orient users.
So we do this by creating
physical relationships between
the objects on the screen so
that the users have a mental
model of where everything
lives and where it goes.
Because, again, we've learned
for hundreds of thousands of
years, physical relationships
and real world, that
translates well to the screen.
So to create an example
of that--
I didn't have, actually, a great
example of this on the
TV that I could have the rights
to use, so we created
our own little example
for you.
And I'm going to run it through
for full time first,
and then I'm going to go back
and try to scrub it with my
track pad here.
So this is a grid of movies
or TV shows in this case.
The user's going to click on
Dexter, and it's going to have
an animation into
a shelf mode.
And there's going to
be piles that open.
So you see a few things here.
Movies by Ray Fiennes.
Then we're going to expand
back out to the grid.
OK, so what's going on here--
this looks like just
animated stuff.
But, let's see.
I've got to do it--
I'm not seeing what you're
seeing, so I'm going to have
to do it here.
OK, so one of these
transitions--
we'll do the pile
animation here.
So there's four steps to this.
So the user is going to
click on the pile.
Click on the pile.
And first thing that's going
to happen is the place that
it's going to go, the shelf at
the top, is going to zoom off
to the left.
See that?
It's going to zoom off to the
left at the same time as the
pile's opening.
Simultaneous to that, the
content of this screen is
going to fade out.
So those three things happen
simultaneously.
And then fourth, the new
content fades in.
And it fades a little fast, but
we want it to feel snappy.
So this is a great example of
the movement, giving the user
a good idea of the physicality,
the physical
relationships.
You open the pile.
The pile opens.
It goes to a place.
You know where it came from.
You know how to get
back to it.
And we actually are building a
lot of transitions like this
in Google TV now.
It actually does require-- well,
it doesn't require, but
we're using OpenGL to do it.
So we actually have some
developers that
know how to do OpenGL.
So it helps to have the
lower-level language both for
speed, but also for things
like lighting and
transparency.
And some of these effects
are easier in OpenGL.
OK, the fourth principle
is make it personal.
Again, we hear this
all the time.
But one size does not fit all.
And yet almost every application
that we build is
the same for every user.
And part of it is because
it's hard.
And so one of the things that
we do is we try to have a
little more modest goal, which
is a technique we use to just
do one thing to make the 10th
experience better than the
first, just one thing
that makes it
personal for this user.
And an example again from the
TV and Movies app, we added
this ability recently to add
your favorite channel.
So you can select to HBO,
CNN, Bravo, Discovery.
But we don't just
show channels.
We show what's on that channel
at any given time.
So that top shelf is what's on
my favorite channels right
now, all together,
all at once.
And so every time I come into
the app, it feels fresh.
It feels personal, feels
like it's made for me.
And there are dozens of examples
of making apps feel
personal, from remembering
States to learning behavior to
providing new options.
But a way that we could go
farther with this one, for
example, would be if we notice
that you're watching
basketball a lot, we can offer
to make a basketball shelf so
that every time you come into
this, it's got all your
favorite teams right there and
who's playing, who's playing
next, where they're playing,
and how to get there.
So the fifth one, surprise and
delight is something we try to
add to every application.
And you can't do it everywhere,
because it takes
time, and it can be
overwhelming.
But we use a technique called
jewel in the warehouse.
And this is a technique that we
borrowed from architecture.
Architects know that no building
built in the last 50
years matches their plans
because of time constraints,
resource constraints,
money constraints.
And so what they do is they
latch onto one element of the
building that is going to be
their special element.
They are not going to
compromise on that.
And so for example, the reason
is jewel in the warehouse.
Imagine walking into this
warehouse, and the architect
had built a beautiful curving
staircase out of
stone at one end.
The user's focus would be so
much on that gem, that element
that they wouldn't notice all
the cruft in the corners and
the things you didn't do
on the sides, right?
So there's a few companies that
I won't name that do this
really well in software.
But the same thing holds
true in software.
And so we really try to pick one
thing that we as designers
in thinking about the
user experience
won't compromise on.
An example here is the
Google Music app
that has this carousel.
And, yeah, it's kind of flip
and maybe a little bit
gratuitous, but it's
also really fun.
It's entertaining, and
it really anchors the
application, gives a center
to the application.
And the final principle number
six is create an
experience, not a UI.
People who design and build
cars think about the
experience that they're
building.
They build a lot of models.
They drive a lot
of prototypes.
They build to think.
They use the building process
to think about what they're
doing through the users' eyes.
And they really solve problems
completely from the users'
point of view.
So what they do, they use this
technique called looking
through the windshield,
which is really--
the concept car is a great
example of this.
They act as if they're users.
They know that who they are
and how they think isn't
necessarily the way their
users think, especially
because they're spending so much
time designing the cars.
And the same holds really true
for application design.
You really need to get out of
your own head and get in the
user's head.
And so we do this through
user testing.
So we've begun just recently to
bring in users every single
week into Google TV.
Everything at every level, every
concept, every model,
every sketch, every mockup,
every prototype, every piece
of code we run through just half
a dozen users every week.
It just takes a few hours, but
it helps us to get out of our
own heads and see it through
other users, through the
users' eyes, from their
perspective, through their
windshield.
So this is a summary of
these principles.
Content's king, less is more,
movement has meaning, make it
personal, surprise and delight,
and create an
experience, not a UI.
So let's see.
I just want to leave you with
one last thought, which is, if
you have the option, grab your
local friendly designer and
get their help and advice.
Designers are trained to think
in many of these ways.
We read publications and
websites and content about
this stuff, and we think
about it every day.
Bringing your app to the TV
shouldn't be that hard,
especially if you're already
in Android or
building in the web.
But it helps to know some of
the differences between
devices and some techniques like
this to make it smoother.
So let's see.
I'll have Ossama come on.
Thank you very much
for listening.
And I hope [INAUDIBLE]
challenges.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
Want to go next?
OSSAMA ALAMI: Yeah.
I'll note that there is
a Sony party tonight.
They're giving away 500
of their new devices.
All you need is a Google I/O
badge, and the first 500
attendees will get
this device.
If you want more detail,
talk to the Sony
folks at their booth.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: It's
a pretty cool device.
I've been using it at home for
the last couple months.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Yeah.
I love their new remove.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
All right.
So we have about 10 minutes for
question if anybody has
questions and wants
to grill us.
You guys can't.
You're not allowed.
AUDIENCE: Can I fire?
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
You know those devices you
showed with the remotes?
I don't know whether you
have that information.
With that cursor touch pad,
can those devices support
double touch so double touch
actually kind of drags it, and
then single touch actually just
kind of moves the cursor
like we do on the
Apple or other--
OSSAMA ALAMI: You could
build that.
By default, that's
not the behavior.
But in your application, you
could design such that a
double touch activates drag.
AUDIENCE: But the hardware
will support it?
OSSAMA ALAMI: The hardware
will support it.
Yes.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: One more
note as you're leaving.
The design guidelines that
I referenced are
available at this URL.
And the slides will
be posted as well.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Just quickly, the
update looks really great.
I think it's a drastic
improvement over
the previous UI.
So thank you for that.
One thing I noticed--
some small things missing.
Is there a reason why you can't
turn off the screen?
These are hooked up
to audio devices.
Normally you don't always want
the TV on all the time if
you're listening to music
hours on end.
OSSAMA ALAMI: That's
a good question.
Google TV sometimes is built
into the TV, so turning off
the screen--
AUDIENCE: There doesn't seem to
be an intent or anything--
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: Means
turning off the TV, right?
OSSAMA ALAMI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But you want
the audio on.
Or similarly, like, listening
to audio while you're
browsing the web.
Those things seem to be still
tricky to accomplish.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: You should
be able to do both of
those things.
So Pandora, for example, you can
play Pandora and then go
to web browsing, and it should
be able to multitask.
But yeah, they're
a little tricky.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so I
had a question.
The Nexus Q was launched
yesterday, and it seemed to be
a cloud player from Google Play,
whereas Google TV seems
much more app-oriented.
Is there any plans to merge the
two and bring Google TV to
the Nexus Q?
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: We can't
comment on plans yet.
The Nexus Q really is a device
for streaming music and video
from Google Play and
from YouTube.
And Google TV is really a
platform that integrates web
and applications and linear TV
and is built into lots of
different devices, TVs,
and buddy boxes.
So they're solving different
problems right now, and we
can't really comment on how or
whether they might merge or
come together in the future.
OSSAMA ALAMI: We'll do another
one from here.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about content.
As you said, content is king.
And we really don't have
that much content
outside of the US.
And that goes for the entire--
the Play experience.
So Nexus Q is a perfect example
for a device that just
won't work outside of the US.
And Google TV has the same
problem, because people don't
have any incentive to buy
one outside of the US.
I was wondering if you guys had
a master plan to fix that?
OSSAMA ALAMI: You know, it's
something that we're
constantly working on, local
content and bringing more
content to TV, both in the
US and internationally.
I think in many ways, we look to
the developer community to
help bring that content,
especially local
content, to the TV.
That's why we built a platform
that you can easily build for.
But there isn't anything that I
can comment on in terms of a
master plan to work on that.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: I really
believe that a lot of the
revolution is going to happen
outside of the US, especially
because there's so many
different experiments already
happening in the UK and France
and Korea where they've got
pure IP TV plays.
And they've got to Catchup
TV already on the web.
And so we really look to
countries outside the US to
help propel it as well
as inside the US.
So you can be sure we're looking
at that very closely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Why don't we
do a question from here?
AUDIENCE: Guys, thanks for
rolling out to Australia.
You might not have
had a choice.
It would be great if you could
have lunch with the Google
Music people and sort
of encourage them
to do the same thing.
That would be awesome.
So question--
accessibility in Google TV,
is it early days yet?
I saw a great talk yesterday
about Jelly Bean
accessibility, and things have
really come forward.
Obviously the blind and
television doesn't really work
so much, but you've got captions
for hearing impaired
and so forth.
Has there been much work
done on that, or is
it a bit too early?
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: We're
built on Android, so when we
upgrade to the next version
of Android, we get all the
accessibility.
So we're really looking to the
Android team for most of those
platform capabilities.
And we'll take advantage
of them as
soon as they're available.
OSSAMA ALAMI: But stuff that's
uniquely video-oriented is
stuff that we're focusing on,
like closed captioning.
Take a question here.
AUDIENCE: It seems to me
before Google TV can go
mainstream, you probably need
a different input method.
Something like a
simple joystick
would be a lot easier.
Are you guys experimenting with
different input methods?
Because a keyboard is--
you don't want that sitting
in the living room.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
Yeah, we're
definitely aware of that.
We learned a lot of lessons
from the first generation.
Although, it's interesting that
a lot of people actually
do want-- it's a narrow
population, but for some
people, a keyboard
is really great.
So as an accessory you can buy
for your TV to do a lot of
input, it's great.
But definitely agree with you
that the main interaction
model, we need to evolve that.
And I would love to bring
something closer to touch, or
we may leap beyond.
But we can't comment on exactly
what we're doing, but
we're definitely spending
a lot of cycles on that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Over here.
AUDIENCE: So with respect to
some of the design guidelines
you gave and taking into account
the fragments API that
was introduced in Honeycomb to
try and unify the APKs-- like
Flixster takes advantage of
that to have one APK that
works both on phone
and tablet.
Is there any way that you guys
would hook into default
fragments that if people use
them, you could sort of build
in some of these
design things?
Like it would automatically
have a darker
screen behind it.
It would automatically
transition the text to
slightly larger in list
view, stuff like that.
OSSAMA ALAMI: I think
we're careful.
We are an Android device.
So we're careful in not
making assumptions on
behalf of the developer.
So we do publish samples and
libraries that make it easier
to get started and sort of
have our UI principles
embedded in them.
But in terms of changing the
default behavior of certain
Android widgets and fragments,
that's not something that
we're looking to do.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: So like
I said, I think we're really
at the beginning of even
figuring out how to make great
designs on TV that can perform
on all these devices.
And as we learn patterns, we
are really interested in
figuring out ways to get them
into your hands either if it's
just a document that's written
about how to do it, code
snippets, examples.
And so over time, I'm really
committed to trying to get
that out there.
We win if the applications
are great.
And whatever we can do to
support that, we will try.
But we're not at a point
where we have
anything to announce yet.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Over here.
AUDIENCE: So you guys mentioned
that personalization
is really important.
But the TV is basically the most
impersonal object in the
home, whereas everybody
in the family uses it.
A computer is really good at
handling multiple users.
A tablet is really good at being
a single-user device.
A phone is being owned
by a single person.
But the TV, it's something that
everybody wants to use.
So how do you manage the balance
between allowing
everybody to have a very
personal experience with still
managing the fact they you don't
want to alienate anybody
that uses the device?
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: Yeah.
Yeah, the fact that it's shared
list doesn't mean that
it can't be personal.
I think it can do both.
Like the shelves that we talked
about and adding favorites.
We're looking at ways to add
favorites for each person in
the household.
So it's still personal, but it's
personal to each person.
Also looking at ways that we
can understand who's in the
room and give recommendations
that are different for two
people than might be
for each individual
person, find overlaps.
So there's a number
of different ways
we're looking at that.
But yeah, you're right.
It's a shared device, but we
still want to make that
experience personal for the
people that are in the room at
any given time.
AUDIENCE: Regarding the cool
transition that you showed us,
you mentioned you used OpenGL.
Does that mean you had to throw
away all the life cycle?
And is that something
you recommend, or
how can you do that?
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
I can't comment on--
I'm not a developer, so I
don't know exactly how
they've done it.
But I know that we're building
some musical libraries
internally based on OpenGL
that are exposed into the
Android layer so that we can use
them in the right places.
OSSAMA ALAMI: And we're working
on bringing those
libraries to the developer
community.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you comment
a bit on the
link with linear broadcast?
Because most TVs still consume
linear in the evening when you
have large [? demand ?]
for it.
So how does Google TV-- because
you can't really do
overlays over linear TV.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Right.
AUDIENCE: Commercial
problem, so--
OSSAMA ALAMI: Currently we don't
support any way to embed
or overlay over linear TV,
although it is a very common
feature request from the
developer community.
I think we're trying to solve
the user experience problem of
how to do that right before we
expose it to the thousands of
apps out there.
And we want to make sure that
it remains a good user
experience across
all those apps.
AUDIENCE: I think you're going
to really struggle.
Broadcast needs to keep their
commercial boundaries, and
people overlay adverts
and everything.
And it's a big security concern
with the broadcasters.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: Yeah,
we do the inverse where we
support PIP across
all applications.
So you can be running Chrome
and still be watching a TV
show, but the inverse
is harder.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Is there any plan to
make the Google TV source code
available, like making
it open source?
[INAUDIBLE].
OSSAMA ALAMI: We have nothing
to announce at this time.
AUDIENCE: Is there a reason that
voice wasn't included as
one of the-- it seems like
the most natural.
Kinect's doing it.
Being able to kind of talk to
your TV instead of trying to
type things in and such.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
Yeah, it is.
I mentioned that it's one of
the interaction models that
are coming, but it's coming.
So it's not something that we're
ready to talk about or
announced or that
kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: You did allude to the
time frame that the next
release was coming out though.
What was that?
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: Just for
the keyboard becoming optional
in the next release, that was
the only thing specific that I
talked about.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Was there a time frame?
I think you said--
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
The next generation.
So the current generation that
you see out there today is
required to have a keyboard.
The next generation is not
It's optional.
So you'll see the keyboard
start to disappear.
But I didn't comment
on the voice.
OSSAMA ALAMI: It's worth noting
that LG remote and the
Sony remote both have
microphones now that ties into
Android search.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, basically, you
guys are dealing with LG,
Sony, and historically it was
the Logitech and new devices
going to be coming out.
Are you doing anything about
those devices which are coming
out of China?
I mean, just have the Android
4 on it or 2.3 on it?
I mean, is there any control
you guys have on those?
OSSAMA ALAMI: You know, that's
not really something I can
comment about.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER:
Yeah, I mean,
Android's an open platform.
Anybody can use it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it has Google
Play, so you just publish your
app as Google TV pretty much.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: As we can
attest, it's very, very
hard to get everything working
on a TV, all the codecs and
all the new chip sets
and different
things you want to support.
Part of what we do for
developers and for OEMs is to
do all that work for you and
hand you Android++ that lets
you focus on the apps
and services you
want to build on top.
But if third parties, OEMs want
to build it from scratch
from Android, then you're
welcome to.
AUDIENCE: Just a related
question, fundamentally, is
there a difference between 4 and
the Google TV version of
it or it's pretty
much the same?
OSSAMA ALAMI: Between?
AUDIENCE: Android 4 and
the Google TV version.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Google TV is
heavily optimized for the
TV-watching experience.
I mean, one of the most obvious
differences is that we
support linear TV.
So we have an HDMI in, and
we do HDMI pass-through.
And it's really about bringing
the web to the TV-watching
experience that users
already have.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL SUNDER MEYER: All right,
thank you, everybody.
I think we'll call
that a wrap.
OSSAMA ALAMI: Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]